bien oui tout le monde le sait et tout
le monde le sent et moi qui ai pu me
rendre dans beaucoup de villes de france
au cours de ces trois dernières semaines
le fait nouveau c'est la renaissance du
parti socialiste toute la politique
française va changer en tout cas elle
peut changer si vous le voulez au fond
c'était notre objectif
à epinay sur seine et il ya maintenant
près de deux ans lorsque nous avons
décidé de rassembler tous les
socialistes dans un seul parti notre
unité à nous et il faut le dire
ce n'était pas si facile il fallait
rassembler des courants différents qui
avait connu à travers l'histoire
beaucoup de difficultés enfin maintenant
c'est fait et à travers tout notre pays
on sait que si la politique française
peut prendre un nouveau cours à partir
de biens du mois de mars
c'est parce que de tous les côtés notre
parti existe parce qu'il est fort parce
qu'il eut puissant parce qu'il a su
rassembler des courants du courant
traditionnelle du socialisme et puis les
courants modernes et puis voici que dans
d'autres secteurs d'autres formations
d'autres mouvements de pensée par
exemple combien de chrétiens
le socialisme rassemble aujourd'hui tous
ceux qui travaillent à la libération de
l'homme
alors notre beau petit fou c'était tout
aussi naturellement de faire de ce parti
socialiste l'une des trois grandes
formations nationales de notre pays avec
le parti conservateur celui qui nous
gouvernent aujourd'hui enfin encore pour
quelques semaines et avec le parti
communiste
au fond le socialisme c'est la seule
réponse apportée depuis plus d'un siècle
depuis le début de l'ère industrielle
aux structures et aux erreurs du
capitalisme voilà eh bien nous voulons
apporter cette réponse alors à la suite
de la campagne qui a été lancée par les
gens qui sont au pouvoir
on nous y crie évidemment vous êtes où
vous serez les otages des communistes
dans l'accord que vous avez passé avec
côté otage c'est un mot face et c'est un
mot polémique moi je ne devrais pas qu
on rabaisse la politique française à à
ce niveau est ce que je vais dire moi
que monsieur giscard d'estaing est
l'otage de monsieur pompidou que
monsieur servan-schreiber est l'otage de
monsieur lecanu est vraiment nous ce
n'est pas notre façon de discuter
d'abord on ne s'en prend pas aux
personnes ensuite nous avons plus de
considération pour
mais autre idéaux pour les autres
objectifs pour les autres partis
politiques
je viens de le dire à l'instant le parti
socialiste est un grand parti fait c'est
autour de cela je crois que vont tourner
les élections si on nous fait confiance
et bien de tous les côtés à la fois je
le répète exprès chacun va pouvoir
espérer chacun va pouvoir travailler
alors voilà à partir de là otages ça ne
veut rien dire et puis je veux préciser
un peu mon point de vue voyons en tant
que français nous sommes français tous
ici et nous essayons de nous comprendre
autant que possible nous aimer est il
possible d'admettre a priori que 4 à 5
millions de français peut être plus
parce qu'ils votent communistes vont
être exclus de la communauté nationale
est ce possible
est ce admissible même si on a des
différences des divergences et en tant
qu'homme de gauche en tant que
socialiste nous cherchons à défendre les
intérêts du plus grand nombre du million
de domme de femmes d'enfants ceux qui
sont les oubliés de la croissance des
opprimés des exploités
le travailleur des producteurs et les
socialistes les communistes ainsi que
les radicaux de gauche
ils défendent tous ces gens là ils
défendent toutes ces taxis catégories
socioprofessionnelles ils défendent ce
que j'appellerais ce front de classe c
classe sociale alors ni en tant que
français ni en tant que socialiste nous
ne pouvons accepter a priori que soient
éliminés les communes quant à savoir de
quelle façon nous entendons développer
les thèmes du socialisme qui nous est
chère naturellement nous avons une
préférence les préférences socialiste
cela c'est une autre affaire seulement
je voudrais qu'on soit tous d'accord
ensemble ici pour considérer que les
élections
cela doit permettre à tous les français
sans exception de dire leur opinion et
le cas échéant de parvenir à la
direction des affaires publiques